mit haustieren können wir erinnerungen
sammeln die uns ein leben lang begleiten
der 99-jährige ron grant im erinnert
sich zum beispiel immer noch an seinen
hund spot den jüngeren jahren immer zum
fischen mitnahm erinnerungen wachzurufen
aus denen sich neue gespräche und
interaktionen entwickeln gehört zu den
aufgaben von robotern bis bit er ist
einer der bewohner des pflegeheims auf
care im südenglischen bournemouth unsere
bewohner lieben ihn einfach und er macht
süchtig man hört einfach nicht auf ihn
zu streicheln
obwohl er kein echter hund ist erzählt
diana bounce die managerin der
einrichtung
sie werden einfach aktiver wenn sie im
sessel sitzen und gerade ein bisschen
bösen dann werden sie sofort wach wenn
sie den hund herren und nehmen kontakt
sie besonders bewohner mit demenz hilft
der hund dabei sich zu entspannen sich
zu erinnern und am leben in der
einrichtung teilzunehmen
noch so ein roboter hunde zu
therapiezwecken in großbritannien nicht
üblich in japan hingegen sind runde wie
bizkit schon lange ein hit